bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
sur sociologue et je pensais pas que je
veux c'est différent en traitant
davantage de littérature voilà j'ai fait
des études assez littéraire avant de
faire la sociologie
donc voilà je lis beaucoup j'aime
beaucoup et littérature est pour moi la
sociologie se trouve aussi dans les
romans dans les théâtres
donc là je vais présenter la
bibliothèque on va regarder un peu ce
qu'on peut y trouver puis vous présenter
leurs ouvrages
voilà déjà ma bibliothèque se présente
comme ceci voilà donc j'ai un peu
délicat qui prennent à droite à gauche
en plus mais pour l'essentiel ils sont
rangés la voilà c'est une butte à qui
est pas mal
agrémenté niveau accessoires il ya une
oeuvre de son grand-père et puis
quelques petits objets ramenés de
voyages etc
g bluetec co-organisé par catégorie puis
par ordre alphabétique
au sein des catégories enfin dans la
mesure du possible donc on va commencer
va par le haut avec cet immense pile de
livres de philosophie
donc je vous avoue que je ne nie pas
trop de philosophie au quotidien c'est
beaucoup devra éviter de la période de
prêt par mais évidemment il y en a qui
sont très intéressants je ne sais pas
que que ça ne m'intéresse pas mais juste
que je n'aime pas ça au quotidien et
notamment je pense dans les ouvrages de
philo qui m'ont alors celui avec lequel
j'ai le plus dommage commencer par lui
c'est heidegger j'ai pas s'il ya
d'autres lecteurs d'heidegger parmi vous
mais vraiment j'ai eu une en mal à
accrocher cet appui au fait que je parle
pas du tout l'allemand
je sais pas mais en tout cas c'est ce
n'était pas une lecture facile pour moi
est par contre l'ouvragé que je sois pas
le plus accessible et qui moi m'a
vraiment intéressé gérer que c'est le
cri ton de platon c'est un texte qui
très court mais très puissant je trouve
en fait c'est un délai philosophique
dans laquelle socrates et son ami pluton
dispute
socrates se trouve alors en prison et il
est condamné à mort et donc l'at on
donne la parole à secrets
notamment pour expliquer pourquoi il
refuse le projet d'évasion qui a vu
qu'il est présenté par mark rutte ont
donc pourquoi il faut ça mettrait en
danger en fait la vie démocratique que
de refuser le jugement même injuste qui
est prononcé à son égard
je trouve que c'est vraiment un texte
majeur que ce soit pour faire comprendre
les principes de la recommandation ou
que ce soit pour s'initier à la
philosophie
je trouve que c'est un texte de
référence et qui est assez facile
d'accès au final ensuite j'ai dû théâtre
donc voila tout ceci alors au niveau du
théâtre j'adore le théâtre je sais je
pouvais avoir toute une vie paris de
théâtre chez moi je ferais je pense ce
qui m'a le plus marqué niveau théâtre
celle du théâtre contemporain
ça va sûrement être beckett et notamment
en fin de partie
c'est vraiment un des ouvrages en
préféré au niveau du théâtre
je ne m'en lasse pas je les relis
maintes et maintes fois pas envoyer il
est vraiment très petit nid c'est court
mais c'est extrêmement puissant vraiment
le se vit dans la peur fois que j'ai lu
j'étais en première et je ne savais
faire jeanne je l'avais jamais réalisé
qu'on pouvait faire ça dans le théâtre
en fait c'est la première pièce
contemporaine que j'ai lu et ça a été
une plaque complète parce que là il ya
ce jeu enfin déjà c'est totalement
nouveau dans le théâtre déjà de l'époque
et puis encore maintenant c'est quelque
chose de très particulier avec des jeux
de mots des qui entraîne toute une
réflexion philosophique les situations
totalement hors du commun et c'est une
lecture extraordinaire voilà si vous
l'avez jamais vue en fin de partie
c'est à la lecture c'est très
intéressant mais évidemment alors
j'espère sera possible bientôt c'est
vraiment à voir sur scène je recommande
à 1000% c'est à chaque fois des mises en
scène
différente parce que cette grande
liberté comme dans la mise en scène
parfois grandiose parfois très
minimaliste et ça donne toujours un sens
différent à ce texte qui est plus riche
je recommande famille également
je pense que je pourrais citer ionesco
pour les noces et rose qui m'a beaucoup
marqué c'est un test qui m'a vraiment
fait grandir dans ma réflexion aussi
politique clairement puisqu'en fait les
personnages se transforme peu à peu en
rhinocéros et à mesure qu'une menace qui
pourrait s'apparenter à un régime
autoritaire avance dans la société
là encore sur scène c'est vraiment
impressionnant puisque sa demande des
moyens techniques et des ou du moins
d'une création d'abord du metteur en
scène qui sont super intéressante série
9 du 20e qui est passionnante ce qui est
très riche en suis-je et notre catégorie
ici alors qu'il ya un petit peu mixa
mais pourra passer les ouvrages de
littérature turque du moins de
littérature anatolienne voilà pour
inclure un peu les différentes cultures
des peuples qui y vivent dans la soupe
est actuel alors la séance hésité mais
vraiment mon ouvrage préféré c'est du
souffle au taciturne de s'abattit mali
avec un roman incroyable vraiment c'est
un auteur donc de vient de turquie
c'est qu'on va dire la s'inscrit dans la
littérature anatolienne le titre
original en fait c'est une soupe de
coulis jack elles n'ont pas eu le
souffle taciturne mais en fait c'est un
show que c'est beau comme titre et en
plus ça reflète assez bien le caractère
de ce personnage mais que yusuf
il ya un personnage que du coup j'ai
vraiment l'impression de connaître un
point fin vraiment la construction des
personnages dans ce roman et c'est un
incroyable vraiment c ils font partie de
vous pendant tout ce livre et je
ralentissais ma lecture pour pouvoir
rester en plomb temps avec eux alors je
suis forcément familière de la culture
anatolienne et de l'histoire de
l'anatolie de l'environnement et la
turquie mais
c'était pas le premier roman que je vous
conseillerais si vous n'êtes pas
vraiment intéressés par la turquie mais
en même temps c'est un plus beau roman
sur la fin de l'empiré ottoman avec
toutes ces rats complexité est en fait
en tant que doctorante en sociologie
c'est vraiment fascinant en fait au
niveau les rapports de pouvoir dans les
communautés rurales
c'est très intéressant c'est très
émouvant aussi c'est un roman digne du
cinéma parce que c'est extrêmement bien
écrit c'est très cinématographique
c'est vraiment une pin pitt et je sais
que ce livre est assez difficile à
trouver
je crois qu'il n'a pas été réédité
depuis un bon moment et c'est très
dommage d'ailleurs de manière générale
sabatinelli qu'un auteur vraiment majeur
dans la queue de la turquie
contemporaine qui a été assassiné pour
ses idées politiques
un auteur qui a vraiment écrit des
textes magnifiques et le plus connu
c'est alors made man of work of donc
madonna en manteau de fourrure la madone
un manteau de fourrure peut être un
français je sais même pas s'il est
traduit en français c'est un roman qui
est vraiment là pour le coup son roman
best-seller qui est pas mon préféré
honnêtement mais qui est aussi
intéressant mais vraiment il suffit d'un
soutien je vous raconte à 100% ces
gamins un poète
il a également écrit un roman semaine le
diable qui est en vous pas de une
écriture très très riches et qu'ils
gagnent à être connus vraiment un acteur
majeur du xxème siècle selon voir et
j'espère que vous le décourager parce
que c'est écrit et j'ai également ses
livres de ces latine et mirte âge qui
ont été écrits en prison qui sont très
intéressant très facile d'accès pour
ceux qui ne connaissent pas du tout la
culture anatolienne j'ai une pile un
petit peu aléatoires
je lave ou de douvres âge on va dire de
il ya un roman qui traîne au milieu de
ça mais c'est parce qu'il est trop grand
pour aller ailleurs mais le reste c'est
pour l'essentiel voire des ouvrages plus
tôt
on va dire d'actualité et or là j'ai
vraiment une partie littérature et
notamment ici vers pas mal de classiques
et beaucoup de livres que j'ai dû
étudier en classe notamment la
chartreuse de parme que j'ai adoré quand
on l'a travaillé en hypokhâgne il me
semble et gourma du zola ans que j'adore
chez passer sa rage en vigueur but de
tim autour de zola voyager arpin c'est
un peu long à lire mais par contre c'est
vraiment passionnant
victor hugo que j'adore annie ernaux et
à oui alors colette les dialogues de
bêtes c'est vraiment un ouvrage
génialissime sur moi alors si j'ai une
mission qui est vraiment abîmé qui me
vient de ma maman il avait étudié
je pense au coulage avril c est vraiment
chaud que c'est un test qui ont un peu
lire un très jeune je crois que j'avais
10 ou 11 ans la première fois que je les
lui est en fait à chaque fois
alors c'est très facile d'accès et le
temps c'est ce genre de livre ou à
chaque fois vendredi
on découvre de nouvelles choses on voit
d'autres aspects de la réaction de
l'autre hills
voilà c'est un texte est très riche et
très beau que je vous recommande et de
manière générale
l'oeuvre de colette qui est une frise un
petit peu mise au second plan alors
qu'elle est vraiment voilà c'est une
figure littéraire essentiel écriture
ensuite j'ai de la littérature alors un
peu plus contemporaines mais ya quand
même un peu de tout là encore il ya
quand même pas mal de choses différentes
j'ai pas vraiment tout apprécié
notamment tous que bernard werder et
c'est vrai que j'ai un peu du mal à
accrocher stefan zweig ça c'est top
et c'est trop dur de choisir que
seulement quelques temps vous présenter
mes voyages à beaucoup de références
différentes je pense que americana je
m'endors gosia dietschy c'est vraiment
un les romans marquants des derniers à
dernières années ainsi vincent outre
atlantique
nous avons donc le roman americana 2
chez maman d'agouazi a dit chic et non
une motrice nigériane et étasuniennes
je pense qu'elle va voir les deux
nationalités et si le premier roman que
j'ai eu des dons dans sa version
française
honnêtement c'est vraiment une lecture
très agréable choses très fluide
c'est le récit en fait de donc du retour
au pays
clobert in et gerald qui vit aux états
unis depuis plusieurs années voilà
comment elle va en fait retrouvé son
pays mais aussi à ses connaissances
d'adolescence notamment son amoureux de
l'époque
voilà et c'est un alors moi en fait
c'est une géographie que l'on connaît
pas du tout honnêtement le nez géré
assez c'est pas là j'ai aucun repère
donc quand didier géographique mais
également sociale et que ça c'est mal
ajoute que je n'en connais pas et de la
découvrir à travers ce roman ça a été
vraiment très intéressant pour moi je
trouve que ça avance bien
tous droits historiques tous les
relations de pouvoir qui pèsent sur ces
personnes qui ne partent vivre des états
unis puis qui reviennent en afrique est
donc ici au nigeria voilà c'est
également des moments très forts sur la
vie de sans-papiers d'un très beau
moment de notre époque un autre roman
qui m'a vraiment marqué qui me vient
d'autriche et c'est une actrice donc 2
du début
enfin me 20e on va dire et autres x-men
marlène au chauffeur je suis pas du tout
sûr de la prononciation roman qui
s'appelle donc le mur invisible qui a
été mais vraiment une grande lecture
pour moi reconnaît dans quelques mois
éprouvante comme lecture mais en même
temps génialissime que je vous
recommande à 1000% c'est une autre issue
que je ne sais pas du tout c'est le
premier ouvrage que j'ai une idée elle
est c'est l'histoire d'une femme qui en
autriche se rend dans les régions
montagneuses pour en visite à des amis à
une époque où l'eau courante explique
éric restée ne sont pas arrivés par tous
et un soir elle décide de rester à la
maison tandis que ses amis par terre en
ville
et le lendemain la vie passe le
lendemain elle se rend compte qu'ils ne
sont pas rentrés et au bout de bien que
vous l avenir à s'inquiéter vouloir se
rendre en ville pour voir ce qui se
passe et en sur son chemin elle se
heurte à un mur cas ne voient pas leur
invisible qui l'empêchent de passer et
elle réalise que ce mur est probablement
en train de lancer arc l'est comme s'il
ne cloche en fait était tombé au dessus
d'elle et de son habitat et que la vie
en dehors de cette cloche s'était arrêté
donc à un peu cet événement presque les
dauphins parfait c'était le nom de
science fiction qui vient elle pas
surveiller donc
la vie de cette femme est plutôt que de
vouloir comprendre qui comment pourquoi
est-ce que ça cloche là qu'il est tombé
dessus
en fait elles varient de manière très
rationnelle à se dire qu'elle va devoir
organiser sa vie en autonomie complète
en fait sa survie au sein de cette
cloche et c'est un carnet de bord
qu'elle commence à rédiger pour ne pas
perdre le fil est d'abord surtout pauvre
dresser l'inventaire de ses stocks et de
ces semences et serra est en fête a fini
par raconter son quotidien avec ses
émotions ses difficultés elle nous fait
part de toute son organisation pour
survivre des animaux qui l'entourent de
ceux qui la touche de comment elle subi
le rythme des saisons notamment des
hivers très dur etc
c'est un roman qui me touche énormément
départ ces thématiques puisque je suis
très sensible aux questions liées à la
nature à l'agriculture et notamment aux
femmes dans l'agriculture
de par ma thèse donc forcément c'est un
livre qui m'a passionné je pense que si
on est intéressé par les thématiques de
déco féminisme déjà c'est un recommandé
pour sûr et de manière plus générale
tous condamnent les carnets de voyage
mais du coup là un grand voyage
totalement immobile c'est fascinant
c'est extrêmement intéressante et bien
équipe c'est un voyage en soi en soi
même en elle même
en l'occurrence qui est magnifique et
comment elles se reconnecte par la force
des choses son environnement aux animaux
qui l'entourent et comment
elle comprend à quel point les
interdépendantes des fêtes comme elle
dit qui sont autour d'elle alors sans
vous spoiler la fin et donne un tout
nouveau regard roman d'ailleurs que mal
dans ce que j'ai commencé à le relier en
ayant vu la fin qui a été une claque
complète et qui fait de ce texte non ça
va un grand récit à la fois par sa mais
également une faute et que sociale très
forte
voilà je vous recommande à 1000% les
yeux fermés ou de marlène au chauffeur
je suis pas sûr qu'on prononce comme ça
bref roald dahl ces navires assurent
jeunesse mais j'adore et là j'ai encore
quelques romans alors n'y a pas que du
roman le premier notamment antoine les
glisse c'est pas un roman c'est un
témoignage d'un homme qui a perdu sa
femme dans les attentats au bataclan
bon c'est très bien ça fait pleurer mais
c'est très beau esau city qui l'a été à
tueur sud africaine que j'ai bien aimé
c'est assez intéressant
violette leduc la bâtarde superbe
ouvrage vraiment une lecture qui est
malheureusement assez peu populaire j'ai
l'impression en dehors de certains
cercles de même léonora miano alors j'ai
un peu du mal à lire ses romans
bon vous me direz si vous connaissez ce
que vous en pensez mais voilà moi je
trouve pas ça très facile d'accès et
ensuite en dessous j'ai toute une partie
qui est vraiment de la littérature
scientifique dans des ouvrages de
sciences sociales de sociologie ni
d'histoire là est encore toute une pile
qui se cache voilà des revues
scientifiques à des choses qui me sens a
été la prépa des master's mais tout ça
est en dessous j'ai dont des ouvrages
d'enfance
voilà de compte et sinon des revues
scientifiques et mails documents
administratifs alors pas très
intéressant dans ce meuble si je vais
avoir sur le haut tout ce qui concerne
la poésie voilà donc il me fait une de
mes formes de littérature préféré alors
il ya un trou ici qui normalement
accueille les
fleurs du mal de baudelaire mais que
j'ai prêté à ma soeur il ya un mais
recueille 2 quand même favori je dirais
que mon préféré
si je devais en choisir qu'un ce sera
sûrement ce recueil de gerland je suis
une grande fan de verlaine
c'est pas très original mais j'adore
également je ne saurais que trop vous
recommander rythme et de manière
générale tous les recueils et toute la
littérature d'andrée chedid qui est une
femme que j'admire énormément et madaya
ans comme andrée chedid et ses ouailles
que l'ordre alphabétique et pas
forcément respectée cahier d'un retour
au pays natal d'aimé césaire çà ou là je
bouge tous enfin gaffe
c'était vraiment une grande claque lutte
est là quand j'étais au lycée je
remercierai jamais assez
mon prof de littérature de l'époque de
marx et découvrir aimé césaire ah oui
s'il ya du mi6 qui est un poète iranien
que j'aime beaucoup et il ya un peu de
mythologie par ici voilà l'ag de la
pléiade
j'ai notamment eu en cadeau c'était pour
des noëls ou des anniversaires je pense
j'ai l'oeuvre complète d'aragon qui
magnifique passe vraiment un très beau
cadeau qu'on a fait c'est passionnant
jeu parce qu'ils avaient déjà eu la
chance de voir une pléiade
mais quand vous êtes quand vous aimez un
auteur c'est vraiment une source
exceptionnelle de à la fois des
correspondances des poèmes sont vraiment
des oeuvres complètes passionnante et de
même j'ai les oeuvres complètes de
rimbaud car nommé pour être reconnu
également
et au milieu de ça se cache non pas une
poétesse mais bien une autre il donc
plutôt de romans et j'ai une vision
assez par une très belle édition d'un
s'est plusieurs fois qu'il ya quatre
romans de d'octave mirbeau et notamment
le jardin des supplices et il ya aussi à
l'intérieur le journal d'une femme de
chambre qui a mes romans préférés très
grand auteur là encore que je trouve
très peu étudié ce que moi j'ai
découvert passé récemment alors que gm
fait des études assez poussées en
littérature j'avais jamais entendu
parler de mirebeau alors que honnêtement
parce que
extrêmement riche et beau et socialement
plus intéressant hop un site si on
descend alors là voilà les les fans
regretteront j'ai la série des harry
potter
il manque deux dents alors que je les
avais tous sûrement des prêts à des amis
bref
et là j'ai des bd voilà donc plutôt des
des as où il ya aussi ce roman de
littérature jeunesse
alors je sais pas si vous connaissez la
passe miroir c'est un roman qui rate au
japon j'avais beaucoup entendu parler en
bien
et honnêtement j'ai eu vraiment du mal à
le lire je pensais que j'allais adoré
après j'ai pas forcément fans de
fantastique à la base mais vraiment j'ai
eu du mal à le finir j'ai trouvé que
c'était pas forcément je sais pas j'ai
pas accroché que ce style de loterie ce
nitro avec l'univers pourtant c'était
très prometteur selon moi mais bon donc
voilà si vous avez lu la passe me voir
n'hésite pas à me dire comment pensez
donc là j'ai encore des bébés
c'est vrai que j'aime beaucoup ça et
j'ai un gros livre d'histoire ici qui ne
rentraient pas ailleurs alors cette bd
que j'ai adoré qui m'a été offerte et
pas longtemps
donc c'est les grands espaces de
gastines monique j'aime beaucoup son
style de dessin je trouve que c'est très
sensible également au niveau de bas de
ce qu'elle raconte l'importance de la
nature dans la construction et dans le
cheminement artistique voilà ce quelque
chose qui me touche beaucoup et qui est
très beau une très bonne bd sur la
résistance d'ailleurs ici par la
résistance et de marginal l'occupation
allemande bras c'est une guerre mondiale
les culotté de paix d'abbas jeu est-ce
que je dois vraiment dedans et ça c'est
vraiment des super bd notamment si vous
avez des jeunes autour de vous parce que
ça fait découvrir en fait des destins
voit la fin des grandes figures
activistes externe féminine en
l'occurrence
d'une manière dont on les présente pas
forcément habituellement et yeda
ministre et faire une petite série télé
qui a été adapté à un patient des bd qui
est excellente aussi donc je recommande
sinon alors la rame du futur moi je suis
fan de l'eat ça tout d'ailleurs imams
eng 2 il va falloir que je remédier à ça
mais j'adore ce qu'il raconte dans ses
dessins en fait j'aime tout ce qui
produit de manière générale j'adore ces
films etc
c'est vraiment quelqu'un que j'admire
énormément et bon bah je pense que voilà
bd qui m'a le plus marqué que j'ai
découvert il ya bien 6 7 ans c'est
persepolis de marjane satrapi ou marjane
satrapi pas trop comment on prononce
donc c'est notre israélienne qui raconte
sa jeunesse et a vraiment une belle et
magnifique
alors moi j'ai une édition en turc donc
ça n'a pas forcément donné un aperçu de
ce qu'il ya à l'intérieur mais en tout
cas c'est une bd qui m'a énormément
marqué qui raconte la jeunesse donc avec
de cette crise dans l'iran au moment de
la révolution
comment également elle a fui vers
l'autriche et une manière générale en
fait ça me montre la montée d'un islam
politique et comment ça affecte des
personnes qui sont plutôt progressiste
et de gauche dans le cadre de sa famille
et c'est une très belle bd
il y avait clairement un film qui a été
tiré de sa petite bd que je remonte
également c'est très très bien dessinés
vraiment les dessins sont magnifiques
très bien écrit c'est passionnant et ça
permet de venir j'ai tous mes cours je
crée pas donc là c'est assez remplie
voilà des classes avec la soirée des
casseurs et cet atlas qui est magnifique
qui m'a été offert par mes collègues
m'ont départ de l'entreprise
je travaillais et ensuite ici il ya
quelques petits souvenirs de voyages et
de en sus de natal et par ici je vais
avoir des
d'épisodes des romans avant des
biographies ou des autobiographies en
l'occurrence vraiment un pour moi la
référence c'est simone veil je pense est
incroyable et en dessous j'ai d'autres
biographies
voilà où conduit la fij et j'en ai un
espagnol d'ailleurs du temps où
j'arrivais encore à bien lire un
espagnol voilà pour ceux qui connaissent
m à mon obsession de jean louis aubert
depuis que je suis cru l'hygiène j'adore
voilà et puis j'ai encore quelques
moments qui sont dans les caisses de vin
ici donc j'ai des dictionnaires
voilà donc mary higgins clark qui était
une grande période de mon adolescence
mais bon le policier et je pense qu'on a
fait le tour de l'essentiel après j'ai
encore des livres sur un peu traîné
droite à gauche notamment des nouveautés
mais je voulais présenterait peut-être à
une autre occasion
eh bien j'espère que cette vidéo vous a
plus que vous avez pu découvrir des
ouvrages que voilà vous avez peut-être
envie du jour met à la lecture dans ce
cas dites moi dans les commentaires si
vous connaissiez tous les livres que je
présentais si vous avez quand même des
découvertes six mois qui vous ont donné
envie
si vous n'êtes pas du tout d'accord avec
moi sur certaines certains commentaires
d'ouvragé voilà n'hésitez pas à venir
tout ça et puis je vous retrouve très
vite pour des vidéos sociaux et en
pendant deux sets
une belle journée
[Musique]